ja danke für die vorstellung ist sehr
interessant was man über mich so alles
im internet erfährt ja ich möchte mich
erst mal bedanken dass ich die
möglichkeit meine projekte vorzustellen
man aber ist wie gesagt darüber mache
ich habe bei uns an der lmu an der
unterrichts mit ja und ja ich betreute
unter anderem das portal unterricht
online.org das heißt wenn es hier den
zweiten beitrag aus der lehrerbildung
praxis portal und das werden wir uns
jetzt hier kurz mal ansehen einer
unterrichtspause zu uns der name klingt
immer etwas sperrig wie sonst machen wir
zurückgemeldet klingt etwas altbacken
das hat einen guten grund wir sind
nämlich genau genommen schon etwas
sperrig und altbacken
wir sind nämlich schon seit 1963
uns gibt es seit 1960 ist für 61 des
jubiläums
wir wurden damals in bonn vor dem herrn
shop der herr abgebildet ist der urlaub
von der lmu abgeworben und deswegen sind
was ein ende der 60er jahren dann auch
unsere der eu zu dieser zeit war es noch
überhaupt nicht dran zu denken und
internet oder virtualisierung oder etwas
ähnliches da war das medium film und
fernsehen was ganz was neues und was
ganz was aktuelles und der praxis rob
hat sich damals gedacht ob man dieses
neue massenmedium nicht auch für
massenveranstaltungen einsetzen kann und
wir bei uns in den leonce vorlesungen
drin ist der weiß gibt es vorlesungen
die teilweise mehr als 1000 nutzer haben
und 1000 studierende und die sind
entsprechend ganz passen veranstaltungen
da hat man probiert unterricht und
aufzuzeichnen
das heißt er wusste diesen 1000 wörter
bringt man nicht erinnern in einem
klassenzimmer rein sondern dann hat man
die klassenzimmer in ein stuhl geführt
das ganze in den unterricht
aufgezeichnet und den dann in den
vorlesungen vorgeführt und gesprochen
das ist mal ganz kurz schauen die
es ist nicht mein eigenes bild aber ich
hoffe man sieht mich und hat mich genau
momentan sind wir eher bekannt für die
folgen aufzeichnungen
also das ist forschern dieses portal wie
die online hna.de gibt abschluss der
knapp 20 jahren wir sind bei uns ja an
der fakultät elsass und im markt
gebraucht also das motto unterrichts mit
steht da eigentlich für eine politische
auszeichnung einige im auditorium sind
ja aus der lehrerbildung haben ja gott
aus dem vorfall gehört trotzdem möchte
ich für die anderen kurs misst einen
kontext mit geben
für was braucht man denn eigentlich
unterrichts absender normalerweise ist
es so dass man mit einem seminar also in
der ersten phase der ausbildung oder
dann in der zweiten dritten phase mit
einem seminar lehrer im unterricht hält
man macht weiß ein unterrichtsbesuch
schaut sich den unterricht an und
bespricht es dann mit dem dozenten nach
das hat den vorteil dass man authentisch
mitgekriegt wie ist wirklich unterricht
läuft allerdings hat es einige nachteile
der anderen wenn jetzt irgendwas
vorkommt dass man gern noch besprechen
möchte oder der dozenten auch besprechen
möchte ist es natürlich dann schwierig
dann darauf zu hoffen ist wirklich jeder
von den studierten das ganz mitbekommen
hat da hat das medium video den vorteil
dass man ja das ganze festhalten wie
holt man machen kann das heißt man kann
im nachgang die aufzeichnung anschauen
bestimmte sequenzen herausgreifen und
sehr intensiv besprechen
und es geht im endeffekt nichts verloren
zusätzlich hat man die möglichkeit
verschiedene perspektiven einzunehmen
das bedeutet normal das ist so beim
unterricht besucht muss jetzt hinten
drin und sieht eigentlich so wie früher
als schüler den unterricht von ganz
hinten aber der unterricht besteht ja
nicht nur daraus dass man den lehrer
sieht sondern ist es ja auch interessant
aussieht in der lehrer liegt er in
ratlose gesichter gibt es unterricht
störungen die er vielleicht die basiert
und da gibt es mit unterrichts auch zu
einfach die möglichkeit diesen kontext
komplett abzubilden in dem man auch
sieht was sieht in der lehrer das sind
nach auch ein kurzes gewitter wenn man
sich das ganze vorstellen kann
und das ganze ist natürlich sollte
schneller einfacher flexible verfahren
als unterricht besucht das heißt ein
video vorzuführen in meinem zimmer ist
deutlich einfacher als alle studierenden
in eine schule zu bekommen
vom genesungsprozess noch ganz abgesehen
was kann man damit didaktisch machen zum
einen werde handeln reflektieren das
bedeutet man sieht hat sich eine
christoph sandmann und diskutierten mit
den studierenden wie hat der lehrer
gehandelt hat worden ist gut passt das
zu dem was man vielleicht vorhin der
präsenzveranstaltung gelernt hat so
didaktische theorie also mannschaft ja
quasi die brücke zwischen theorie und
praxis
man kann sich best practice beispiele
anschauen also wo es unterricht wirklich
gut gelungen
oder vielleicht auch manchmal unterricht
wo man noch verbesserungspotenzial
findet man kann die aufzeichnungen für
qualität in forschung verwenden das
heißt sehr viele aufzeichnung nach
bestimmten theoretischen aspekten
durchforsten und daraus bestimmte turin
abzuleiten und war es jetzt auch gerade
zweiten dritten phase der lehrerbildung
gemacht wird wird auf basis von unseren
unterrichts aufzeichnungen genügt aus
dem seminar lehrer ulrich zu beurteilen
ist damit der unterricht möglichst
objektiv auch von den zukünftigen
lehrern beurteilt wird
dann kann man auch schon mal langsam zu
unserem portal
wer schon mal eine unterrichts abzeichen
durchführen wollte hat gemerkt das ist
gar nicht so einfach von der idee
tatsächlich dann zur tatzeit zu kommen
muss erstmal schulen und klassen finden
die mitmachen dann ist ganze genehmigen
lassen von den schülern von den eltern
von den lehrern von der schulleitung und
von der vorgelagerten
schulaufsichtsbehörden aber auch für
rechtssichere einverständniserklärungen
die wirklich heiklen definieren was
damit gemacht werden darf wird auf das
ganze sinn
datenschutz ein sehr heikles thema wie
man gerade eben auch schon kurz mal
diskutiert haben was man konnte nicht
diese videos irgendwo youtube hochladen
sondern wir uns wirklich schauen dass
das im einflussbereich des
datenschutzrechtlich sauberen systems
bleibt also am besten nichts aus der
universität heraus geben
diese auszeichnung zu machen ist auch
eine gastregion sport event verschiedene
perspektiven das heißt man hat die
schüler den lehrer gleich die gesamte
klasse noch und dann vielleicht
übersicht mit allen perspektiven dann
der ton bedingt sich immer hält das
handy hin und dann hat man den ton und
des videos fast aber dann merkt man
schnell unterricht ist kein ständiger
ort der leise ist sondern wird
gefrühstückt werden studie hin und her
gerutscht da
versteht man vielleicht den lehrern noch
gut aber das schüchterne mädchen links
hinten das auf eine frage antwort
versteht man halt überhaupt nicht mehr
das heißt auch dass technisch
einzufangen ist nicht ganz triviale das
ganze muss man auch die arbeiten
verschiedene perspektiven verschiedene
touren muss man können und dann noch wo
können wir das ganze bereit bestellen
einem das ist nutzbar ist und trotzdem
noch datenschutztechnisch im
sicherheitsbereich dass man kann sich
vorstellen das ist ein relativ hohe
kosten und zeitaufwand unter von der
idee wirklich zu einer brauchbaren und
einsetzbaren unterrichts zeichen zu
kommen und da haben wir jetzt wir unser
angebot unterricht ohne netlock wo wir
unsere zwei experten zusammenführen zum
einen den betrieb des videoportals den
letzten 20 jahren machen mit
vorlesungsaufzeichnungen und den die
erstellung von unterrichts
auszeichnungen die wir jetzt knapp seit
60 jahren machen und bieten das jetzt
hier in unserer stadt
zum einen komme ich jetzt einfach unsere
unterrichts videos verwenden die wir
unter einverständniserklärungen gedreht
haben die die nutzung kontextbezogen in
der lehre aus fort und weiterbildung
gestatten wenn da nichts dabei ist aber
man hat selber aufzeichnungen gibt es
auch die möglichkeit eigene videos bei
uns mit einzubinden in den eigenen
seminaren und wenn man gerne andere 18
hätte unterstützt macht gern bei der
produktion nicht nur von unterrichts
aufzeichnungen sondern auch allen
anderen filmaufzeichnungen die im
universitären kontext anfallen
vielleicht als kurze werbeblock wir
haben mehr redet von der hochschule für
film und fernsehen
sie können den filmen die können
schneiden das heißt wir haben da
wirklich qualifiziertes personal
vorhanden
das ganze wird dann noch umrahmt wird zu
den kursräumen indem man den unterricht
aufzeichnungen einsetzen kann
das schauen wir uns doch auch gleich in
einer praxis beispiel an und wir haben
eine web anwendung entwickelt die
spezifisch für diesen anwendungszweck
optimiert ist ursprünglich war sie vor
allem für die fans aufzeichnungen aber
auf feedback von nutzern haben wir das
immer weiter entwickelt aber so dass
jetzt sehr viele didaktische szenarien
hier abrufbar sind
[Musik]
jetzt kommt dass spanien teil für mich
die live-demo ich hoffe es funktioniert
alles ich hätte backup folien aber wir
haben so auch in geringen genau ich
hoffe dass ich jetzt meinen browser
falls dem nicht so wäre
bitte ich mir ja zu widersprechen ich
suche dort noch meine maus kommt hier
sind wir auf der startseite unterricht
online.org da kann jetzt jeder
theoretisch mal drauf schauen
man kann sich entweder von der us- oder
auch von anderen universitäten das
wissen inzwischen deutschlandweit tätig
und haben ganz verschiedene projekte
auch von verschiedenen hochschulen bei
uns mit drin und da kommen jetzt schon
ersten wichtigen punkt den zustimmung
von den datenschutzbedingungen das hat
nämlich jetzt gleich eine auswirkung
darauf was ich zeigen kann
wir dürfen nämlich unsere unterrichts
aufzeichnungen nicht über fremde server
streamen und dazu noch nicht den
bayerischen freistaat gehört darf ich
keine live unterrichts abzeichen
darstellen aber wir sehen ein anderes
wieder sehen können dass das gemisch
dann trotzdem vorstellen
das heißt wir locken unsozial wenn man
einen muss der nutzer ja da sehen wir
schon drin
vorher wurde schon mal thematisiert wie
findet man den eigentlich die videos
also wir finden die nutzer die das den
content dort präsentierte suche
implementiert das heißt wenn ich jetzt
einen grundschule prozent gehen und
möchte jetzt hier unterrichts
aufzeichnet grundschule haben sollen wir
schauen was gibt es da von der
grundschule schönes jetzt gern was aus
der dritten jahrgangsstufe und sie hat
damals religionsunterricht und
sprachunterricht sie jetzt verschiedene
latifah schon mal was da drin ist könnte
jetzt ja drauf klicken und schon während
der unterrichtszeiten drin so schnell
ging das allerdings darf ich wie gesagt
jetzt drauf klicken
also das wird man die unterrichtszeiten
sind deswegen war kleinen schritt weiter
wir haben auch kurzfilme implementiert
da hab ich jetzt einfach mal einen demo
kurs raum in dem ich unverfängliches
material platziert habe ich bin jetzt
auch hier der kursleiter des kurses die
gisela ob verschiedene möglichkeiten den
kurs zu administrieren
das heißt so ähnlich wie sieht es aus
wenn das einmal gemacht hat dann ist es
ganz schwierig an teilnehmer haben
wollte machen wie das hinzufügen
aber da gehen jetzt nicht im trend ich
habe uns doch mal endlich unterrichts
aufzeichnung an
genau jetzt den big buck bunny die kennt
vielleicht der eine oder andere das ist
ein open source für ich bin kein team
hier verwenden
wir stellen sie trotzdem vor das wäre
ein unterrichts aufzeichnungen sie
kommen jetzt dazu anschauen und habe
jetzt die möglichkeit direkt während der
film die perspektive zu wechseln
ich habe jetzt installation ist mal 30
reduziert und noch mal gemacht das heißt
ich hätte die möglichkeit wenn es winter
nicht schnell genug ist wie in einer
sportübertragung zwischen den
verschiedenen perspektiven hin und her
zu schauen um mir die unterrichts
aufzeichnungen aus dem app store
inzwischen als direktes möchte und jetzt
plötzlich etwas auffällt sagt
beobachtung die ich für mich festhalten
markt klicke hier auf dieses symbol da
und sagt ob die möglichkeit diese
beobachtung für mehr versteckt ist zu
stellen das heißt sie sehen durch oder
auch der der kursraum leiter dem dem
fall auch ich ja oder auch öffentlich so
dass es die anderen ziehen würden und
dann stelle ich das ganze was wir dass
ich hier diese beobachtung niedergelegt
habe das heißt ich habe eine zeitliche
differenz was es mir erlaubt wieder an
diesem zeitpunkt ihn zu springen wird
dann interessant wenn ich die das ganze
für mich vor strukturierte schade ist im
vorhinein an und kann in der live
präsenz veranstaltung direkt an sich
stellen hin springen die für mich
besonders relevant sind
das heißt dass zur vorbereitung ich
konnte diese information die jetzt hier
bin es auch menschen denen zur verfügung
stellen das heißt wenn ich jetzt
beobachten veröffentlichen
sie ist jetzt öffentlich sichtbar für
alle studierenden kann ich jetzt
beispielsweise anweisungen geben oder
erläuterungen zu bestimmten grenzen
ich habe auch die möglichkeit hier wie
in den vorraum zu antworten
das heißt die erste chronik
kommunikation wir hier mit drin
das heißt sie können die aufgabe stellen
mit 3 1 sätzen oder diskussions aspekte
und da direkt in der plattform mit den
studenten in interaktion treten das
heißt man hatten das medienbruch das
messer und nach motor über wechseln muss
man gar nicht genau weiß auf was wird
geantwortet sondern hat das ja alles ist
jetzt hier integriert
da gibt es noch viel mehr sachen aber
dafür haben jetzt in der kurzen zeit
jetzt leider zu wenig zeit enden
weiterhin das bett möchte ich noch
zeigen haben wir auf der rechten seite
auch die möglichkeit zusatzmaterial
einzubetten
das heißt hier kann ich installationen
transkripte aufgabenstellungen alles
mögliche machen ablegen und untere
anderem auch keine guten systeme
das heißt ich habe jetzt ja einfach ist
kathrin system positiv negativ ist
didaktisch jetzt vielleicht nicht
hundertprozentig als gedacht da kann man
sich aber letztlich leicht was darunter
vorstellen verhindern dass in workshops
und trainings workshops recht gerne dass
wenn ich jetzt das unterrichten schaue
ich sagen okay ich habe jetzt hier ein
beobachtung ich glaube was wo sie sicher
ist die seen gibt es hier und sie dass
das ganze zum einen ein gefährt bereits
hoffnungen
also wir haben eine farbliche referenz
ich habe das ganze mit dem hashtag
verschlagwortet was ist erleichtert sehr
schnell die sachen wieder aufzuwerten
und ich konnte die ganze nationen und
die beobachtungen dann im nachgang
exportieren
manchmal ein weiterer unterschied
das heißt rituell sehe ich sofort direkt
an der station gehört das ganze und kann
es dann im nachgang arbeiten genau das
nächste mal kurz zur präsentation zurück
es hat funktioniert das heißt wir können
ein mikrofon überspringen
wir haben jetzt ein gebührte unterrichts
aufzeichnung der hartmanns klar ist die
lehrkraft ist wo die perspektive bei uns
ist die der schüler oder die schülerin
mit der lehrkraft gerade integriert hier
eine gesamte klassen perspektive und
dann habe ich noch eine perspektive über
alle perspektiven einmal drauf habt das
ist das was wir hier sehen
das heißt ich kann mit diesem auge
einfach jedoch klicken und mit jahren
sind die unterstützung bis zu sechs
perspektiven
deswegen drücken auch tatsächlich
verwendet das heißt man kann ist sehr
intensiv betrachten
der kurs richtet es ja dass die videos
die ihr gezeigt werden im kursraum
eigene instanzen senden das heißt wenn
mit dem fitness gearbeitet werden soll
dann darf das nicht aber solche
talgemeinde liste passieren sondern nur
im kursraum drin hat dann im guten
effekt natürlich dass alles was hier
passiert an dotationen zusatzmaterialien
alles in diesem raum verbleibt und nicht
nach außen dringen so dass man jetzt
keine beeinflussung von anderen hat
wer sowas möchte müsste für uns wird es
ein administration kann man selbst
machen das heißt man ist ja auch relativ
flexibel und nicht auf uns angewiesen
wenn man da was ändern möchte diese
beispiele können wir überspringen
es gibt natürlich eine sprungmarken
zusatzmaterial sachen die man von
einzelnen plattform entsprechend
erwartet jetzt möchte ich noch ein paar
beispiele zeigen wie man das den
komplexeren didaktischen szenarien
einsetzen kann
hier sind jetzt auch beispielsweise die
möglichkeit aufgabenstellungen mit
einzubinden das heißt die studierenden
sehen jetzt erstmal ins sequenz haben
also die ersten fünf minuten
schaut man sich einfach mal sagen lasst
es auf sich wirken und dann irgendwann
wird der herbst kommt mit eingeblendet
und auf diese aufgabe kann man dann
antworten das heißt ja studieren klickt
jetzt mit ist ihre antwort einsatz zum
beispiel klicken gibt es eine antwort
rein schreibt es nicht spar hat ab und
dann geht es weiter
das heißt das wird in ein projekt
verwendet um die lernstandserhebung
durch die studenten durchzuführen das
heißt der kursleiter sieht was die
stücken entsprechend geantwortet haben
sieht wo zwar wird es verstanden was
muss noch besprochen werden wie weit ist
dann in der notengebung jetzt weiß ich
jetzt endlich sagt nicht täglich alles
möglich aber genau das wird ja mehr oder
weniger auf diese art und weise
eingesetzt das heißt man hat jetzt die
möglichkeit beliebig viele
aufgabenstellungen auch mit vision
antworten gab es auch mal die budgets
hier zu unterlegen und alles direkt in
dieser unterrichts beobachtung situation
einzusetzen
ich habe ich jetzt ein praxisbeispiel
wie wir unterrichts video mal mit diesen
einfachen kategoriensystem verwendet
haben
das szenario über folgendermaßen wir
haben personen gehabt die in der
lehrerausbildung tätig sind größtenteils
welche die auch tatsächlich andere
lehrer bewerten also simona rektoren die
haben einzelne gruppen aufgeteilt haben
gesagt schauen sie doch bitte mal die
ersten zehn minuten von diesem video an
und marschieren die sequenzen wo positiv
für sie waren uns sehr wenn sie negativ
waren
und hier sieht auf den ersten blick
es war viel positives dabei vielleicht
noch leicht negativ aber es hätte ich so
die waage selbst vor wie das video
insgesamt beurteilt worden ist
hier unten sehe ich dann den zeitverlauf
brot ist wieder negativ und grün ist
positiv
das heißt die erste der einstieg war
relativ günstig bewertet von den gruppen
aber jetzt sehen wir dann gleich schon
mal dass einer zeitlich sehr nah
zusammen gelingen stelle also 148 fand
die erste krippe toll
die zweite gute chance der ist nicht so
gut und die produktive fans wieder gut
das ist jetzt ein aspekt den man sich
jetzt dann heraus greifen kann im
präsenz bereich und darüber zu
diskutieren
das heißt zuerst schauen sich die
gruppen das ganze an und notieren das
oder bewerten das einzeln ohne
beeinflussung dann macht man kurz pause
veröffentlicht das ganze dass jeder
alles sieht und dann kann man wirklich
direkt live in der seminar sitzung dann
vergleichen wo sind die
übereinstimmungen ist dann vielleicht
nicht ganz so interessant
aber wo gibt es dann vor allen dingen
unterschiedliche einschätzungen die man
diskutieren kann und dann auch
vielleicht nur materie tisch fundiert
anschaut was vielleicht andere
alternativen gewesen werden und
vielleicht noch mal etwas komplexeres
beispiel da ging es darum dass
lehramtsstudierende unterrichts
beispiele selbst gehalten haben die
haben in einem seminar für die tour
lehrerinnen und lehrer erstmalig das
stilmittel gelernt wie man sich im
unterricht präsentieren soll und sich
dann selbst aufzeichnen lassen und
wurden dann von ihren peers nach diesen
stilmitteln dann beurteilt oder quasi es
wurde ihr feedback gegeben so dass man
direkt sehen können an welchen stellen
sind noch sequenzen immer verbessern hat
oder wo ist was besonders gut passiert
das ist nur ein beispiel bild ist es
nicht aus dem leib fortsetzung kann ich
das jetzt auch zeigen
aber so ähnlich kann das ganze
vorstellen genau das heißt mit dem der
plattform bieten wir eine sehr breite
bandbreite von didaktischen szenarien
von einfachen ich zeigt dieses video bei
mir in der präsenzveranstaltung und rede
darüber
bis zu einem mehrstufigen komplexen
blended learning szenario wo die
studierenden das ganze erst zu hause
selbst anschauen und beobachtungen
niederlegen oder aufgaben beantworten
dann kann man der zweiten phase feedback
sich gegenseitig geben lassen in dem
dieses jahr kommt der tag funktion
freigeschaltet wird
in der dritten phase kann man sich dann
alle sachen anziehen und schaut sich
dann in der vierten phase dann im
präsenz an welche sequenzen sind den
besonders diskussionswürdig wo kann man
doch mehr darüber reden
na ja vielleicht noch als kurzen
werbeblock zu setzen nach hinten dran
wir machen bei uns an helmut diese
aufzeichnung betreuen diese plattform
sind allerdings auch offen für andere
hochschulen das waren ja auch andere
hochschulen mit dabei das heißt wer sich
dafür interessiert da mit teilzunehmen
es gibt die möglichkeit wir kommen uns
die ganzen technische angelegenheiten
man kann auch fremde streaming server
von anderen qualitäten anwenden wenn es
notwendig ist corporate design
anpassungen werden von uns auch gemacht
und ja noch viel mehr wünsche der
wichtige aspekt ist dass wir das ganze
selbst entwickeln das heißt wenn man
irgendwelche featuregäste einsatz schon
gut aber hier und da bricht man
irgendwas dann haben wir die möglichkeit
dass tatsächlich noch mit in der
anwendung mit einzubauen
und wo sind eigentlich die ganzen
funktioniert hätten entstanden immer aus
der praxis eine rückmeldung was hätte
man denn noch gern und wir haben
geschafft was man finden und umsetzen
kann und so haben wir jetzt eine jahr
glaube ich relativ potente möglichkeit
unterrichts aufzeichnungen in forschung
und lehre einzusetzen
somit bin ich nach 29 minuten hier auch
schon am ende fragen kann man jetzt hier
gleich noch die antworten wenn nachgehen
dafür sind gern eine mail an und hält
online.org da können wir dann vielleicht
dann direkt man miteinander kontakt
treten und ansonsten würde ich den
bildschirm wieder freigeben und die
fragerunde starten